good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-4459
object class
euclid
special containment procedures
scp-4459 and scp-4459-a
are to be contained separately in two
standard containment lockers at site-81
this portion has been stricken from the
document
scp-4459 and 4459a
are to be contained together in a
standard sized wardrobe made from oak or
maple the wardrobe should also be filled
with other non-anomalous clothing items
acquired along with scp-4459
every two to three weeks the wardrobe is
to be opened and aerated for at least 30
minutes and the items inside should be
dusted and checked for damage
research involving
scp-4459 and 4459-a
should be conducted under the
supervision of head researcher dr jean
stewart and only with permission from
site administration mobile task force pi
6 clown wranglers should also be on hand
in the event of a containment breach
description
scp-4459 is a gentleman's black silk top
hat that shows moderate signs of wear
including notable damage to the crown
and brim
scp-4459 was acquired along with a
matching red silk hat box from an estate
in madison wisconsin on june 14 2017
after local authorities had been called
in reference to a domestic dispute
involving the item
the foundation became involved when the
responding law enforcement officer
reported that one of the belligerents
was dressed like a clown and exhibited
paranormal behavior that corresponds
with documented behavior of the clowns
associated with hermann fuller's circus
of the disquieting mobile task force pi
6 were dispatched to the scene where
they retrieved
scp-4459 and 4459-a
the on-scene law enforcement officer
underwent amnestic treatment and was
issued cover story epsilon delta 12
false report domestic incident the two
belligerents were taken into custody and
later amnesticized and released after
interviews determined that they
exhibited no anomalous behavior outside
of the influence of scp-4459
the anomalous properties of scp-4459
only become apparent when worn
scp-4459 and 4459a collectively are host
to an esotheric entity identifying as
frost this entity claims that at some
point in the past it was imprisoned via
anomalous means inside the hat and its
corresponding box by the ringmaster of
group of interest 233
any non-anomalous human wearing the hat
becomes possessed by this entity and
begins to exhibit several anomalous
qualities that they would not normally
be able to express
these abilities correspond with
documented behaviors attributed to the
entities known as the clowns that are
primarily associated with group of
interest 233
scp-4459 and 4459a were collected along
with numerous items of clothing that are
assumed to have belonged to c.h
wilkerson the deceased former owner of
talia lane madison wisconsin while most
of the clothing collected were of an
antiquated design and style
non-exhibited anomalous properties these
items were initially slated for disposal
but after a request from the
scp-4459 head researcher these items
were retained pursuant to the revised
containment procedures
attached to denda
discovery
the following note was located inside
the interior lining of scp-4459-a
and has been appended to this file as
document 4459 document one
june 11th 1992
fnc
if anyone deserves a rest it's you two
thank you for all the laughter all the
tears and all the service over the years
i hope this gift will help you blend in
where you never could before
icky
addendum initial subject interview 4459
interview one
playing log now
interviewed
scp-4459 and d-2871
interviewer dr gene stewart
forward d-class subject use authorized
by site administration
t2871 assigned
due to the unpredictable nature of the
subject interview was conducted in a
secure interrogation room with dr
stewart conducting the interview via
tele conference
d-2871 was placed in a room with
scp-4459 on a table in the center of the
room d-2871 was directed to remove
scp-4459 from its case and place it upon
their head
begin log 2806 17
10 18 am
good morning d2871
there is a hat in the box on the table
please put it on yeah yeah sure
this is much easier than some of the
other things y'all let me do
d-2871 removes the lid and lifts out
scp-4459
hey
this is of nice
a bit old but whatever
d-2871 places scp-4459 upon its head
a moment or two passed then several
physiological changes were observed to
happen all at once
d-2871 is a member of a non-white ethnic
group and their pigmentation was
observed to shift across the expected
ethnic spectrum to assume an off-white
palace similar to the white clown paint
additionally d2871's deflated state was
observed to change and hair growth was
noted
d2871 would you please describe what you
are currently feeling
i'm sorry doctor
jonathan is no longer available to
answer your questions
a notable tonal shift is noted andy
2871's stance and demeanor is observed
to be markedly different from documented
norms
subject shows significant deviation from
recorded baseline
scp-4459 please describe for me what you
are currently feeling
if i were to choose but a single word dr
stewart that word would undoubtedly be
loss
why loss
have you ever experienced loneliness
doctor
i believe that most people have
then have you also felt the cessation of
that loneliness
transcendent joy that is communion with
an equal a partner
a lover
my personal life is not what we are here
to discuss
scp-4459
then i assume that you have no doctor we
are not discussing your personal
experiences but you asked why i felt
loss
without context the explanation would
simply be lost
not everything can be easily defined by
notation and categorized in your report
then please answer the question
why laws
because without my soul i am nothing
without my heart beating in my chest i
am adrift without the warmth of their
touch
i am alone
so you lost someone
i can understand
doctor i am afraid that you cannot
i don't mean to be rude but it would be
impossible for you to understand the
depth of loss that i have experienced
you have never been forged
i'm not sure what that means
how about you tell me how you became
associated with the hat
i was put there when kai and i retired
from the circus
i was under the impression that the only
way to do that was to be counted by us
or if you were killed
it is never that simple
doctor the circus was hard for some this
is true but for most of us
it was family
and the only one any of us ever really
had
none of us ever really wanted to leave
but i knew that kaia would eventually
have to
why is that
kaya was mortal
extended by milk shore but eventually
they would grow old and i would not
i always knew that falling in love with
kai was going to lead to loss but that
was never even once a consideration
it happened
and i have no regrets
so you retired
both of you
yes
eventually
kaya stopped drinking the milk and i
knew it was time
we requested it
and our request was granted
kai could pass as a normal
but
i
could not
and the hat let you do that
it did more than that
dr stewart
after that exchange
scp-4459 lapsed into silence and refused
to respond to any further questions
eventually d2871 removed the hat and
returned it to its box
closing statement
it is my assessment that
scp-4459 does not present much of a
threat and while i would prefer to
reclassify it as safe i believe that the
inherent unpredictability of its clown
nature makes it so that would be
ill-advised
end log on july 21 2017
scp-4459 breached containment during a
routine cleaning of their containment
area
d2101 had been tasked with janitorial
duties in that section and during the
completion of their task put on scp-4459
after a few moments
scp-4459 returned all of the clothing to
the wardrobe before shifting into an
incorporeal state and vanishing up
through the ceiling the hume level
fluctuation generated by this shift
triggered the containment alert but site
security was unable to prevent
scp-4459 from leaving
mobile task force pi-6 were activated
and they proceeded to attempt to locate
and recontain scp-4459
which they initially failed to do during
the course of their following
investigation members of pi 6 returned
it to madison wisconsin in an attempt to
track down scp-4459
evidence was found that
scp-4459 had been visiting the gravesite
of c.h wilkerson and several items were
retrieved from the scene
document 4459 to
the following documents appear to be
several pages torn from a journal
i'm not sure what that really meant
i do know that kai is struggling to find
a purpose here at the circus and i
really want to help them find a place
poodles and squiggly are very supportive
of my endeavors to make a home here for
kaya and i was surprised that what am i
talking about of course they would be
supportive they always considered me a
younger sibling and they wanted what was
best for me i did not think they ever
expected me to find such comfort in the
arms of a human much less one that was
not even different but what can you say
all i know is that i want the best for
kaya even if that means i ultimately
must let them leave
april 2nd icky came to me with a
suggestion today she has always been
curious about how resistant kaia is to
the more dangerous side effects of milk
and she suggested that we try feeding
them a less dilute version than the
candy i'm not sure if this is the best
route to take but i seemed really
excited about the prospect quote
whatever lets me be closer to you was
all they would say about it i think if
this is the only way to help kia feel
more at home here then i'm all for it
april 3rd kaia got really sick today
after trying the brew that icky made of
she said that it was much stronger than
the candy but nothing like the stuff
that we drink tilly brewed it up for us
and kaya drank it down right away i
guess the good news is that they are
definitely not dead but they fell asleep
and have not woken up yet manny said
that kaya really is just sleeping and i
shouldn't worry
but i cannot help but worry what if
there definitely needs to be something
done about it the show is going way
better than i originally thought it
would kaia is taken to the aerials with
a talent i did not expect and iggy says
that fuller will like having another
show for the big top he's always
grumbling about getting something new
something exciting
he has gotten meaner about it though and
he has started to press us all harder to
do more be more
be better whatever that means the fun
lovers are all restless now and i can
tell that icky is really nervous about
that
may 28th
kaya fell today
june 1st it took a few days but kaya was
finally able to get up and walk around
while not as resilient as we are i was
surprised how little the fall actually
hurt them i keep asking kai either to
take it easy or allow dick to finish the
transformation but they still did not
want to accept the full conversion i
think they're afraid that becoming a
clown would make them different i tried
telling kaia that i would love them
anyway but i can tell that they're
really worried that they would become
something else
i guess i can understand that inky says
she's not the same person as she was
before she became a clown and it makes
sense that kaya would be so nervous
january 22nd the show is going great we
added a few new tricks to the lineup
that we've been working on together and
i'm surprised at how well they fit in
with the rest of the act kai has really
thrown themselves into the performances
and i think that they really have
finally found their place the look on
their face when they're not holding on
to me makes me feel so safe it doesn't
matter that falling would not really
hurt me
i know that kyle will not drop me and
that makes me feel amazing i'm so glad
that they are finally at home
i think i'm gonna get tilly to make
something special
february 13th so much has happened and
i've not really had the time to put it
all down everything seems to be coming
to a head between fuller and manny
they're fighting all the time now and
their yelling matches are really
beginning to take their toll on the rest
of the cast those damn freewheelers are
everywhere now i can't even get alone
time with kaia in the alley anymore
they're always watching always leering
just around the corner poodles said that
we don't have to worry about them that
icky won't let them touch us but i'm
afraid for kaya they're no longer as
fragile as they were when they arrived
but they're still not a clown no matter
how much iggy says they are i ask dick
about whether or not he thinks that
over the next several days mobile task
force pie six maintained an observation
post at the cemetery but as cp 4459 was
never apprehended over the course of
their operation several more documents
were left at the gravesite along with a
collection of toys and flowers
document 4459 3
has finally settled down whatever
happened in the matinee must have been
really bad because neither icky or manny
would talk about it the only thing
either of them would say was that fuller
was gone and was essie's problem now
i'm relieved really we took some time
off for touring and nikki told us that
we could all decide whether or not we
wanted to stay i don't think anyone left
and kai and i talked a bit about it i
know that they're worried about what
things are going to be like without
fuller but things were okay when fuller
was away before how is this any
different
june 16th we're touring again we
returned to prime and we set up outside
of a place called madison wisconsin kai
says they used to have family here and i
think they were actually hoping to see
someone that they recognized they were
disappointed when none of them showed up
but i think that was only because they
wanted to show off the show was really
awesome now and we've even started
incorporating several of the other
clowns into the act lolly wanted to play
around with us too but i don't think she
has the right temperament for it she has
a really good magic show but flying
takes a lot of concentration especially
with a
it's hard to imagine that we've been at
this for so long now kai said that we've
been performing together for almost 23
years
it seems like it was only yesterday
march 4th i don't know what changed but
manny said it's finally safe for us to
go back to prime again i overheard him
talking to ikky about the esses again
but this time he seemed to be saying
good things about them i i don't think
he's ever had anything nice to say about
them but whatever they did he certainly
thinks it was a good thing at least
there's a prime to return to sometimes
i'm glad i don't know all the things he
does
march 11th kaya fell again today and
this time they did not bounce back as
quickly lately they have been talking
about how slow they feel in the morning
i never thought about them getting older
but
no i'm not going to think about that
right now we have a show to prepare for
september 13th
kai has stopped drinking milk we argued
about it but they said it was time that
keeping up with me was becoming too hard
i can tell that they
really want to but even the milk is not
enough anymore i think that fall
affected them more than they expected
i'm scared
i don't want to lose them i think i'll
go talk to icky
september 14th icky has a plan she was
telling me all about part of how the
matinee works and she thinks she can
replicate some of the things that fuller
on july 28 2017 scp-4459
manifested at the grave site once again
but did not leave anything behind but
will task force pi 6 were able to
surround and apprehend scp-4459
without incident
after
scp-4459 was returned to containment
several attempts were made to conduct
another interview but
scp-4459 refused to speak to anyone
eventually dr stewart was able to
convince
scp-4459 to cooperate with a final
interview
and this is subject interview 4459
interview 8 playing log
interviewed
scp-4459 and d-2871
interviewer dr gene stewart
forward
d-class subject use authorized by site
administration
d-2871 assigned initial attempts at
interviewing the subject since
recontainment have all failed i've
decided to try one last time
but i have decided to assume the risk of
interviewing
scp-4459 in a standard interrogation
room i brought along several of the
items left at ch wilkerson's gravesite
in the hope that they will prompt
scp-4459 to speak with me
begin log 1209 17 9 41 am
d-2871 retrieved scp-4459
and placed the hat upon its head
for several moments after the expected
transformation the 2871 remained
emotionless then looked up at dr stewart
good morning did you read them
the journal entries yes i did i i think
i understand your loss a little better
now
maybe
what do you mean
look if you're going to be uncooperative
i will just terminate this the crown
forged us dr stewart it made us one
person
guy and i
well we got to grow old together i never
expected to be able to do that
how was it able to do that
i do not really know to be honest ikky
said that some of fuller's magic
remained behind in his top hat it was
one of the most precious things she
owned from back then she only brought it
out to wear on special occasions
gaia did not want to take such a gift
they said it was worth more than a clown
and an old performer
so it had something to do with you do
not understand
doctor it was not just
a top hat it was his crown it was part
of what sustained the whole circus it
let us know where all of us were all the
time
iggy used it to help keep us safe
without it
i do not know there was a reason the
circus did not visit prime for a while
after we left
that was a really costly gift then but
it meant so much more to us
it let us be together i do not think
that even a key knew what would happen
i guess she thought it would just
function as a kind of disguise but when
kaia put on the crown they
became a human
again
completely
and i was there with them
inside them a part of them for the first
time
i truly knew how much kaya loved me
at last we
won
okay i i can accept that
what happened after that
we moved to wisconsin kyle always loved
it there
it gave us enough of your money so that
we could retire and we just
got old
so
what happens when no one is wearing that
crown
i am not alone anymore doctor
i had to be sure
i'm sorry that i left without permission
but i
i had to say goodbye
that must have been hard for you
i'm sorry
more than you know
would you let me go back to my box now
i'm so tired
okay
thank you for you could you give me back
our things please
i know you still have all the clothing
that you took when you captured me
it
would comfort me
i would like all of our things together
like you found it
i'll see what i can do
thank you doctor
i would appreciate that
you're welcome frost
end lock
closing statement
i am going to request that all of the
items found from the wilkerson estate be
collected and the containment procedures
revised
approved
site director actors
end log
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
zargaron
the morrigan
professor puffer
retalias
karim el ashmuy
allah trayon
your local fishman
derivative
talk of villagers gabriel hawkins
nate the klein
lost boy
african submarine vore
seventy
kristoff kozak slesak
hms lily
the almighty fish
gav the clumsy containment specialist
pure osmium
sciodio demnatus
brian sanchez
matthew gilmore
eric corbin
long guinness
james saba
and
nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen
thank you
you